[Música]
las autoridades prorusas instaron a los
habitantes de jerson a evacuar la ciudad
de inmediato las evacuaciones
organizadas por las fuerzas de Moscú que
controlan la región llegan en medio del
avance de la contraofensiva de kiev y de
las tensiones en La Represa del río
nieper que de ser atacada inundaría la
zona
Georgia melón y juró el cargo de primera
ministra de Italia su mandato supone el
regreso de la extrema derecha al poder
desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial la líder
de hermanos de Italia y ya presentó su
ejecutivo el partido de berlusconi Forza
Italia ASUME exteriores y la liga de
salvini economía
en China concluyó el vigésimo congreso
del partido comunista la renovación del
comité central podría afianzar al
presidente en el poder y asegurarle un
tercer mandato al frente del gigante
asiático
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Francia 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relacionada con la guerra en Ucrania
porque las autoridades prorusas de
gerson región recordemos anexada
ilegalmente a Moscú pidieron a los
ciudadanos que evacuen la zona de
inmediato sin embargo las evacuaciones
empezaron el miércoles y ya más de
25.000 residentes han sido trasladados
según las autoridades regionales
oficialmente las fuerzas rusas dieron la
orden de agilizar las salidas civiles de
gerson por la amenaza de un bombardeo
masivo contra la ciudad recordemos que
esta es la única gran urbe a manos de
Moscú y que el ejército ucraniano la
podría intentar recuperar en el marco de
su contraofensiva
continúa las evacuaciones en gerson con
pocas pertenencias y mucho temor miles
de residentes de esta ciudad del sur de
Ucrania huyen desesperados el ejército
ruso los instó a abandonar sus hogares
Durante los próximos días se espera que
el ejército de kiev realice una
contraofensiva para recuperar el terreno
anexionado por Moscú alrededor de 10
autobuses transportaban refugiados hoy
ayudamos tanto como pudimos movimos
cosas algunos fueron transportados en
minibús a la ciudad otros fueron
escoltados a estaciones suburbanas
Rusia planeaba actuar entre 50.000 y
60.000 personas de la urbe la cual tenía
unos 284 mil habitantes antes de ser
invadida por los rusos al principio de
la guerra Esta es una zona de alto
interés para ambos lados del conflicto
se trata de un objetivo principal debido
a sus industrias clave y Su importante
Puerto fluvial Durante los últimos días
gerson ha sido testigo de fuertes
enfrentamientos alrededor de reclutar
rusos han llegado a la ciudad mientras
las fuerzas ucranianas continúan
aumentando la presión en la región
nos ofrecieron salir debido a la difícil
situación recibimos mensajes de texto
no no tomamos una decisión de inmediato
pero luego nuestros amigos y familiares
nos invitaron y ahora nos vamos a Moscú
esperamos tiempos mejores y queremos
volver a nuestro gerson natal yo anduvo
entre tanto Ucrania pidió el viernes una
misión de observación internacional en
la presa de jacobca quien acusa a Moscú
de preparar ataques que inundarían una
vasta zona del sur ucraniano y por otro
lado este sábado Ucrania denunció
también nuevos ataques rusos contra
infraestructuras energéticas en el oeste
del país y de hecho un millón de hogares
se quedaron sin electricidad por otro
lado continúan las tensiones alrededor
de La Represa de Nova kacoba en el río
nieper que de ser atacada inundaría la
región de gerson kiev acusa de haber
minado la infraestructura para impedir
El Avance de la contraofensiva ucraniana
acusaciones que el kremlin rechaza y de
hecho el ejército ruso aseguró que hoy
repeló varios ataques ucranianos en las
zonas que controla
el enemigo intentó romper las defensas
de las tropas rusas enviando hasta dos
grupos tácticos de Batallón lanzados
hacia los asentamientos de piaticati su
hannover Sabrok y en el lado ese del Río
nieper en la región de gerson todos los
ataques fueron rechazados el enemigo fue
empujado a sus posiciones iniciales
cambiamos de información la
ultraderechista Georgia melloning juró
el cargo de primera ministra de Italia
se convierte así en la primera mujer en
ocupar el mando a la vez que su mandato
implica el regreso de la extrema derecha
al poder desde la caída del régimen de
Benito Mussolini Georgia meloni ya
presentó las caras de su ejecutivo
compuesto por miembros de su formación
postfascista hermanos de Italia junto
con perfiles de Forza Italia formación
que ocupa el Ministerio de exteriores a
pesar de la reciente polémica por las
palabras de su líder sirvió verlusconi
sobre su buena amistad con Vladimir
Putin por otro lado Mateo salvini ASUME
como Vice Primer Ministro y su formación
de extrema derecha la liga queda al
frente de economía humanes sanos amplía
Italia da un giro a la extrema derecha
la líder del partido ultraconservador
hermanos e Italia Giorgio melón Y tomó
juramento como la primera mujer que
encabeza el gobierno de ese país
juro ser Leal a la República respetar
fielmente su Constitución sus leyes y
ejercer mi rol en los exclusivos
intereses de la nación
su ascenso fue celebrado por prominentes
figuras de la extrema derecha europea
como el Primer Ministro húngaro Víctor
Urban o la líder de la agrupación
nacional Marín le Peña en Francia dirige
una mujer pero está lejos de abrazar la
causa feminista 18 hombres y seis
mujeres integran su gabinete Aunque en
el pasado había dejado ver su simpatía
por una Italia fuera de la zona Euro
meloni ha designado a un Pro europeo
como jefe de la diplomacia el ex
presidente del parlamento europeo
Antonio tejani la presidenta de la
comisión europea Úrsula Wonder Legends
ha sido una de las primeras dignatarias
en felicitarla y recordarle las tareas
conjuntas que hay pendientes y el
presidente estadounidense Joe biden
también ha citado los desafíos que
afrontan juntos en la otan en el
gabinete de melón y destaca Giancarlo
georgetti ministro de economía un
militante moderado de la liga de salvín
y partidario de la pertenencia a los 27
5 tecnócratas no afiliados a ningún
partido integran el gobierno de meloni
que ha tenido que imponerse a sus
compañeros de coalición Mate
ambos cercanos al kremlin y de hecho
marcar distancia con el ex Primer
Ministro luego de que se filtraran
audios en los que detallaba su amistad
con Vladimir Putin Y es que la cercanías
ideológicas no son garantía de una
administración unida melón y tendrá que
hacer frente esas diferencias para
llevar adelante su gobierno y cumplir
con sus promesas de campaña como aliviar
el golpe por los altos costos de la
energía reducir impuestos y evitar el
aumento de la edad pensional que
entraría en vigor en enero
y en otras noticias este sábado concluyó
el vigésimo congreso del partido
comunista de china con la renovación del
nuevo comité central que podría afianzar
al presidente en el poder la clausura
estuvo interrumpida por el desalojo del
ex presidente hushing Tao de la sala no
se sabe si el gesto fue un acto de purga
pública o si responde a cuestiones de
salud del ex mandatario Marina sardiña
con los detalles
este inusual gesto eclipsó la clausura
del vigésimo congreso del partido
comunista de China el ex presidente
hugging Tao de 79 años fue desalojado de
la sala tras un breve forcejeo poco
antes de las votaciones del partido y
ante la impasividad del actual
mandatario el partido no ha dado ninguna
explicación de la aparente purga pública
o de si se trató de problemas de salud
se ha logrado el propósito de unificar
pensamientos fortalecer la confianza
aclarar la dirección e inspirar el
espíritu de lucha Esta es una
conferencia para mantener en alto la
bandera reunir fuerzas y avanzar en la
unidad
después de siete días de reuniones el
líder chino sale fortalecido gracias a
las nuevas enmiendas a la Constitución
destinadas a consolidar el estatus
central de Pin por al menos otros cinco
años entre los cambios de en sus
estatutos estaba la referencia explícita
al freno de la independencia de Taiwán y
la inclusión del concepto espíritu de
lucha donde el reitera que es partidario
de la unidad específicamente de la
reunificación pacífica con Taiwán pero
que él estaría dispuesto a utilizar el
uso de la fuerza él tiene como ejemplo
pues lo que ha sucedido entre Ucrania y
Rusia y no quiere cometer esos errores y
él dice que efectivamente Esto hace
parte de que se tiene que resolver de
una forma pacífica entonces lo que
estamos viendo Es que él busca que el
pueblo chino sea el que tome la decisión
y no haya injerencia internacional el
congreso también confirmó la elección de
205 miembros del Congreso central con la
re veteranos como el Primer Ministro
liquexiaong y el vicepre Primer Ministro
wangyang este domingo se conocerá
Quiénes son los siete miembros del
poderoso comité permanente pero parece
que el máximo órgano del partido estará
compuesto en su mayoría porcistas
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en Francia 24.com
[Música]